[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Івківці,
Наддніпрянщина]
Просто наше село дуже розкидане
і його не видно.
Коли заїжджаєш у село
до старих друзів, села нібито немає.
Там є якісь кущі в ярах,
а то не кущі — то царина.
А в царині хати стоять.
[Олексій Заїченко
Екскурсовод Одинцівського млина]
[сміється]
Трохимович, ви ж ротище забули.
Тримайте.
Це — символ Коліївщини,
без цього не можна.
Сам цей вітряк реставрували 2008 року.
Толокою зібралися, гуртом усім селом
і врятували його.
[Назар Лавріненко
Засновник Зерноленду]
Там всередині є фотографія,
який він був до реставрації:
такий геть перекошений уже лежав.
Ми його відновили, запустили,
він був повністю робочий вітряк.
Із цього вітряка, із цієї доброї справи,
нас і понесло.
Це колись був колгосп Горького —
така назва стара.
А перша назва цього колгоспу —
«Нове життя».
Там жеребець пасеться, а там кобила з лошам.
Можете покататися на кобилі зараз,
на ходулях походить, воза потягать,
рікшу потягать, що хочете.
У нас усе можна —
територія, де все дозволено.
Тут був цей згорний сарай.
Ми з місцевими чоловіками і жінками
гуртом стали і побілили його,
кинули балки, крокви,
знайшли якийсь вживаний шифер
і зробили тут спершу музей дітям.
Зібрали із хатів нікому непотрібні речі.
Їх треба брати
отако з-під руки ззаду, бачите.
Ось так взялись [показує].
Раз-два і пішов.
Місцеві діди нас навчили цього.
У нас тут похорони були колись,
і ми замовили ходулі сюди привезти.
І ми як діда поховали того,
а потім кажу:
«Як же на тих ходулях, діди, ходить?»
І вони мені показали саме тоді,
і з того часу я на тих ходулях тут,
у нас обов'язкова атракція сільська наша.
Цю власність передав нам
наш етнографічний музей.
Перед цим музеєм, під накриттям у нас
майстерня з ляльками-мотанками, каламарня,
ткацька майстерня, папірня
і в тому краю гончарна майстерня.
Що ти зробив тільки що? Де твій виріб?
Виріб? Трохи луснув.
То другий роби.
Я просто тут до бабусі їздив.
Якраз почали будувати Зерноленд.
Мені привезли цей гончарний круг.
Я подивився перший на нього, сів,
щось почав крутити.
У мене так получалися якісь вироби різні.
[Владислав Чуб
Гончар]
Мені це просто сподобалось,
у мене з'явилась така робота:
просто показувати дітям гончарство.
Тематичні села —
це взагалі європейська практика,
коли в селах зникли колгоспи у Східній Європі,
то державні програми тоді
були спрямовані на те,
щоб місцеве населення чимось зайняти.
А у нас цього не було.
І от був такий проєкт україно-польський.
Суть його  в тому,
щоб показати нашим селянам,
як це робиться у Польщі,
які там створилися тематичні села.
Нас туди повезли і там тиждень
нас годували, показували ось ці села.
Потім далі двісті євро,
і ми за ці гроші почали працювати.
Коли почали створювати тематичне село,
то тема села була зрозуміла одразу.
У нашому селі є вітряк —
це відправна точка.
Ми відпрацьовували тему зерна як ключову.
Тут у нас святая-святих, наш музей.
Тут колись був згораний кормозапарник.
Вивезли звідсіля згарю ту всю.
Зробили новий дах, нову стелю,
балки, крокви.
Це ось така штука скляна.
Ніби як ядро, але такі ядра були
в кожній хаті у кожної бабусі.
І вони ними користувалися дуже часто.
Вони зроблені із скла, спеціальне гутне скло.
Ось такі шари.
І що ними робили?
А все дуже просто.
Ще з часів Римської Імперії
нагрівались ці гали в печі.
Кладемо її на полотно і катаємо.
Яка прибрана дівка пішла,
які в неї рукава викатані [випрасувані].
От викатували рукава шість років тому
тільки от такими галами.
Річ у тім, що я сам етнограф,
історик, краєзнавець.
Бавлюся в професійного історика.
Я більше працював з теорією, архівами тощо.
Практики у мене не було.
Коли у селі місцеві хлопці кажуть:
«Ти музей збираєш? А в мене ярмо є».
Та не може бути.
І він приносить мені ярмо.
Ярмо розписне із свинцями, полями, гирами.
Такі ярма я тільки у книжці бачив.
А тут вони не те що десь в Україні,
вони в мене в селі.
І я розумію, що це не останнє ярмо в нашому селі,
що цих ярем ще буде багато
і що це все збереглося.
Ми вирішили це зробити таким комплексом:
де надається комплексна послуга туристична,
де діток і дорослих нагодують
де й екскурсію музеєм проведуть
і квест на гору зроблять,
і на конях покатають.
Тобто ми даємо комплексний продукт,
який займає 4-5 годин [часу].
Це так робиться папір із кропиви.
Ось тут замочена кропива,
перемелена, варена п'ять годин.
[Сергій Сербін
Майстер із виготовлення паперу]
І робимо ось так.
Зливаємо зайву воду.
Тут обережно...
потрібно зняти.
За кілька годин
папір висихає
і залишається у нас малюнок.
Що таке, мала, що таке?
Ой ти моя красуня,
ой ти така красива кобила.
Нумо погуляємо підемо трошки, га?
Ох, ти!
[вигукує] Хоба!
Старість.
Це наша Жасмінка.
Їй вже чотири роки скоро буде.
Я от пів року їздив, кожен день її сідлаю.
А в селі не міг триматись [в сідлі].
Оце тільки зараз себе більш-менш впевнено
почуваю в сідлі за пів року.
Її мали на м'ясо здати, у неї грижа була.
І ми виставили на Фейсбук,
що треба врятувати коняку,
допоможіть нам.
І ми назбирали купу грошей.
Відразу півціни зібрали
і за перший привоз заплатили,
але до травня вона вже народила дівчинку.
Ось цю Жасмінку, Жозефінку.
[цілує коня]
Ось це справжня конська любов.
Фу!
Так ти мазуту їла!
Ах ти така!
Фу!
Ось це мої справжні друзі.
Таке заняття дозволило...
не впасти у відчай,
вояка з мене, мабуть ,поганий був би,
на фронт я не пішов.
А ось тут воюємо, як кажуть, в тилу.
Але наша війна непроста, наша війна —
за душу маленького українця.
Коли ти питаєшся у людей
середнього і старшого покоління,
чому ви українською не говорите?
А вони мені кажуть: «Ви знаєте,
я українською не вмію говорити,
а суржиком стидно.
Тому мені легше говорити російською мовою».
Вони все життя спілкуються російською
і цураються тієї живої
української мови своїх дідів.
Тобто те, що внесли ось це клеймо суржика,
це геніальний проєкт знищення
української мови.
[стукає по металу]
Переважно я на тракторі,
на комбайні працював.
А потім коли настає зимовий час,
що готують сільгосп машини
до весняно-польових робіт,
я в кузні працював,
але там такого я не робив.
[Леонід Філоненко
Коваль]
Переважно лемаші треба було тягти,
«вісімки» поробити, тягти боронів зубки.
Коротше кажучи, зробити так,
щоб техніка вийшла в поле.
А тут уже прийшов...
Ну я ж не буду казати,
що я тут буду граділя тягти,
вирівнювати чи влемаші тягти...
Потихеньку також сам від себе
[відштовхуюся].
Те зробив, те зробив,
а дітям тоді цікаво.
[стукає по металу]
Коли розслабишся, якось так усе і відбувається.
Нічого не вимагається від мене
і від наших людей.
Тому що як казали:
«Та я боюся бути ковалем.
Я вмію кувати, але я боюся з людьми.
Ой я там не вмію будувати,
не вмію крутити очеретом».
Кажу: «Не бійся, що гірше, то краще».
Тільки раз і получилося і вже
вдруге ідеально кладеться той очерет,
в'яжуться парки і все робиться.
Так знімається комплекс якоїсь рамки високої —
він розслабляє людей і
дозволяє людям почуватися
невимушено, по-домашньому.
І нашим учасникам проєкту і нашим гостям,
тому що це знімає будь-які обмеження.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Режисер монтажу
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]